-"The Meg" -- you
have described the movie as --
like "Jurassic Park"
meets "Jaws."
-Yes.
-This is a big shark.
-This is a giant shark.
We set out to make the
second best shark movie ever.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And I think
we have achieved that.
-Well, that's great.
-Yeah.
-You got to know
what you're aiming for.
-Yes. We tried to take out
"Deep Blue Sea."
-Oh, interesting.
-You know what I mean?
Little --
Little known shark reference.
-Little known. So you...
-Yeah.
-You -- Obviously, a CGI shark.
-Yes.
-You couldn't get any sharks
to agree to be in this movie.
But --
-They wouldn't do it, yeah.
-But the real -- no CGI --
the real Jason Statham.
You -- First time Wilson
and Statham have teamed up.
-[ As Jason Statham ] "Oh, yeah.
First time with Statham."
[ Laughter ]
"That's right."
-I'd -- See, I would like
to be around Jason Statham.
Is it -- Is it as exciting
as it sounds?
-I am like a fan girl
around Jason Statham.
-Yeah.
-I love his movies.
He is one of the few
action stars of like --
when he says, like,
"I'm going to kick your ass,"
like, you believe him.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-He could kick the crap
out of people, you know?
-Yeah, I believe that,
after takes of his movies,
someone's ass
had actually been kicked.
-Yeah.
-No, absolutely.
But someone asked me in a --
in a press tour earlier,
they were saying, like,
"Well, if you were going to
voice The Meg,
you know,
if it was an animated --
like, who should voice The Meg?"
I was like,
"Well, Jason Statham."
-[ Laughing ] Right, yeah.
-And that would be
an interesting conversation.
It was be like...
"I'm going to make you bleed,
Jack."
And then the shark
would be like,
"Not if I bite you
in half first."
[ Laughter ]
"I'd like to see you try."
"I'm going to swim to you
and bite you with my teeth."
You know, whatever.
-Right.
-You know? You know?
-The sharks are, like,
historically bad at comebacks,
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The shark...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sharks...
-Yeah.
-Sharks like to write
their own material, you know.
-Yeah, they're like, "I want to
just find it on the day."
-Yeah, just --
Yeah, improvise their lines.
-Are you afraid of sharks?
-I am -- I am afraid of sharks.
-Yeah.
-I am also afraid of salmon.
-Okay, right.
-Okay?
[ Laughter ]
I'm afraid of anything you're
going to find in the water...
-Uh-huh.
-...that might swim
somewhat near you.
-Yeah.
-So if it's a guppy or a minnow
or a barnacle or a --
or a piece of kelp
that touches my calf,
I'm like -- I'm like, "Gaaah!"
[ Laughter ]
So I get out of the water.
So am I afraid of sharks?
Yes, I am also afraid of sharks.
-Okay, see...
-So...
-But, like, that's not --
like, it's gonna be like --
there's just this one thing...
-Right.
-...that Rainn's afraid of --
it's not that.
-No, it's anything in the water
that touches my body
other than
sand and water itself.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-And -- And a girl in a bikini.
Other than that...
-But -- But you -- you think
getting eaten by a shark,
if you had to go,
would be a cooler way to go.
-It would be
an awesome way to go.
I mean, think about it --
like, the guy who played Dwight
was eaten by a shark?
It'd be like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-That's badass!
-Am I right?
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
'Cause I -- there are
so many humiliating ways to die.
I had one of those
in my life once.
I borrowed
my handyman Pablo's van
to go down to Home Depot once.
It's a true --
absolutely true story.
And it was
a 1974 Dodge huge van.
And I was --
I pulled it out in traffic.
And I noticed the seat
was too far back,
so I kind of adjusted the bar
and slid it up.
And then my --
it slid over my finger
and my finger was stuck.
And I could barely see
above the steering wheel.
And I'm in traffic.
And I'm like, "Aaah! Aaah! Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm -- I'm --
And I can't find the brake.
And I'm going down
Van Nuys Boulevard like this.
And I -- And I really thought
in my head, like,
"I'm going to die.
I'm gonna die with my finger
under my anus."
[ Laughter ]
And...they're gonna --
they're gonna see me,
and, like, TMZ is going to take
photos of my body,
and this is how
I will be found dead, like...
[ Laughter ]
So I would absolutely love
to be eaten by a shark.
-Yeah.
I hadn't thought of it that way.
But that -- yeah.
-Think about it.
-People -- I'd be reading that,
being like,
"I would have thought he would
have had a newer van."
[ Laughter ]
"The Meg" --
I did not know this.
"The Meg"
is short for "Megalodon."
-The megalodon, yes.
-And this is something
your son knew.
-Yes, it -- it actually existed
like 100 million years ago.
It was the biggest apex predator
that planet Earth has ever seen,
next to Jason Statham.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
And my son was a huge fan
of megalodons.
And he -- my mom actually
sent him a megalodon tooth.
-Wow.
-I don't know
where she found it -- eBay?
I don't know where you get
a megalodon tooth, but --
-How big is a megalodon tooth?
-It's like this --
it's like this big.
-Okay.
-It's like a big --
It's like a big, bony triangle.
-Gotcha.
-And it's sharp.
And my son
would come home from school.
And he'd have an apple
for a snack.
And he'd use it as a knife.
[ Laughter ]
And he would -- he'd be
cutting up slices of apple
with a -- with
a 100 million-year-old tooth.
And that's the crazy life
that TV celebrities live.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Now it's just weird, you know?
Just weird.
-"This is my son.
He cuts his meat
with a megalodon tooth."
[ Laughter ]
You play a -- but you actually
play an eccentric billionaire --
-Yeah.
-...in this film.
And you have -- in real life,
you've crossed paths
with billionaires.
-Yeah, it's an odd thing
that TV actors --
billionaires love to hang out
with, like, sports figures
and, like, TV actors.
-Uh-huh.
-And I've been at --
just at different events
and award shows and parties.
And there's billion --
chockablock with billionaires.
I'm like,
"Oh, there's Elon Musk.
And there's other billionaires
and stuff."
And so
I really based this guy --
he's -- Jack Morris is --
he's kind of the comic relief
and, also, kind of the villain
in the movie.
So it's an interesting
kind of combination.
But I took
some of those qualities that --
that billionaires have --
that, oftentimes,
billionaires have this kind of
like boyish sense of wonder
about the world.
And you'll meet them,
and they're --
they're, like, in Air Jordans
and, like, a track suit.
And they're like, "Hey, wow.
That's cool.
How do these cameras work?
Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
You know?
They -- They --
And that kind of curiosity,
I think,
makes them who they are.
-Yeah.
-But they can also turn
real quick
and you see a dark side,
you know,
where they -- you know how they
got to where they got, you know?
-[ Laughing ] Right, yeah.
-So...
-Right,
the Air Jordans came later,
but the crazy genius part
was first.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-The evil Scrooge
capitalist genius
is underneath
that boyish wonder.
-Well, it's nice
to see that in film,
and it's always wonderful
to see you here.
Thank you so much
for coming back.